So what I shared with you today are
some studies that we have done on
understanding T-cells memory, in
particular cytotoxic CD8 T-cells memory.
T- cells are composed of two major subsets,
the CD4 T-cells which provide help for
antibody responses predominantly and
then you have CD8 T-cells. These are T-cells
that recognize infected cells and
can kill these infected cells.
A CD8 T-cell is the best mechanism that
we have, are the best soldiers that we
have, to eliminate either virally
infected cells or tumor cells, so this is
a very important way of eliminating your
infected cells. The CD8 T-cells can
actually -- they will attach to the
infected cell or to the tumor cell. They
do this because the T-cell receptor will
recognize peptides -- they can either be
tumor antigen peptides or they can be
peptides coming from the virus, for example
if the cell is infected with HIV,
there will be peptides from the HIV
virus which are expressed
presented by MHC class 1 molecules on
the cell surface. So here you've got a
piece of the bar a peptide sticking on
the surface of the infected cell, you've
got a T-cell which recognizes that
particular peptide presented by the MHC
class 1 molecule. That interaction will
result in that T-cell then killing that
infected cell. And so the CD8 T-cells are
referred to as cytotoxic CD8 T-cells or
CD8 t-cells. So when
I talk now in for the next 15 minutes or
so I will use these terms
interchangeably. I might say CTL and I
might say CD8 T-cell but it's the same thing,
a cell that can kill that
eliminate a virally infected cell.
So we used this mouse model of acute infection
to study the properties of memory CD8 T-cells
and what we found was that memory
CD8 T-cells basically can live for the
life of the mouse after vaccination or
after the infection is cleared, and we
have then extended these studies in
humans and shown that people who got the
smallpox vaccine even 78 years ago
have memory CD8 T-cells that recognize
that the smallpox virus. So long-term T-cell
memories maintained not only in
mice but also in humans and can last for
literally 50 years or longer.
So then the question was. how are these
T-cells maintained? And work that we did
along with other people showed that the
T-cells are maintained two ways.
One, they are actually intrinsically
very long-lived.
They can live for many, many years and
most of the time they're just very quiescent,
they're not dividing they're just sitting
as quiescent cells. Likewise I mean
they're not replicating or dividing the
sitting as a cell that's in a g0 g1 phase.
But they also undergo what we and
others have termed a homeostatic
proliferation. That is, they have a stem
cell like property where they can
self-renew. So every few months in a
mouse and every few years in a human,
there's a capacity of these
cells to self-renew.
They will undergo another division to
maintain the numbers, so if there's a slow
attrition or death of these cells
there's also a slow birth of these cells
that maintains numbers at fairly
constant levels for many, many years.
So this is one intrinsic property of a
memory T-cell -- it can self-renew itself
and that's how it's maintained for such
a long period. The other very interesting
property of memory T-cells is that when
they now see the infecting pathogen,
which they can recognize,
they make a very rapid
effector response, and we're dealing here
with cytotoxic CD8 T-cells ,so even
though this memory cell looks
like a very quiescent cell sitting without
any replication, as soon as it sees the
invading pathogen which it
can recognize, it very rapidly elaborates
effector function. And what I mean by
effector function is that it can now
very rapidly kill that cell. So a memory
cell has two properties which are very
different from that of a naive cell --
that is, one that has not gotten this program
of being a memory cell. One, it's much
longer-lived intrinsically, it has the
capability of this homeostatic
proliferation to maintain its numbers,
and it has the
ability to elaborate effector function
very rapidly. And that's t
the cellular basis of memory by CD8
T-cells.
My lab has been interested in
this question for almost 30 years now -- I
was at UCLA when we first started these
studies and then I moved to Emory
University in 1995 and for the last 20
years we have been continuing these
fundamental studies on T-cell memory
both in animal models and in humans and
obviously these have a lot of
implications in terms of optimizing and developing different vaccines.